Speaker 1: Well, the economic situation in the
United States has taken a very interesting turn.
And in particular, if you believe, as I believe
the evidence shows, that one of the greatest
indicators as to how a particular election is
going to go is the perception of how the economy
is doing. Things are all of a sudden looking quite
okay for Democrats and not so good for Republicans
if the average person actually understands what's
going on. And I want to start by looking at the
first interesting indicator for today, and that
is gas prices. Gas prices have now continued to
fall for nearly 60 days in a row and are below $4
per gallon for the first time since March of 2022.
Now, why are gas prices so important? Because
this is our is gasoline really a major expense
for most households? And the answer is not
directly. Certainly, if you're in transportation,
Uber drivers, etc., it's a major thing. If you
have a long commute, it's a major thing. But
there's two reasons why this is important. Number
one, many people look at gas prices as a general
proxy towards are things cheaper, expensive
right now. And when gas is 502 per gallon,
as it was two months ago, there is the perception
that things are generally expensive. And when
gas now drops below $4 a gallon, there's the
perception that things are cheaper. We know
things are cheaper because inflation has started
to come down. But there's another issue with gas
prices, which is so many of the things that we
depend on, food products of different kinds,
so many different things, they come on trucks
and are affected by gas prices as well. So
this is an important indicator for that reason.
And when we look at the GasBuddy price charts,
you will see that there was this peak at about
502 per gallon late in actually early in June. And
then it has been a continued and steady decline
now below $4 per gallon to what looks like let
me see officially what CNN says, 399 per gallon as
of this morning, according to Triple A. So let's
now take a deeper look at some of these economic
indicators. If you step back and you think about
over the last two weeks, what have we seen? Well,
we've seen the stock market increase nicely.
We've seen a blockbuster jobs report where
a quarter of a million jobs were expected
in July and we got over 500,000 jobs, more than
doubling the expectation. Inflation is down.
Gas prices are down. The Inflation Reduction Act
has been signed. The pack or with the Inflation
Reduction Act has been voted approved by the
Senate, and then tomorrow presumably will be
approved by the House and very quickly signed
by Joe Biden. The PACT Act has been signed.
Wages are up. And then on the other hand, you have
Donald Trump raided by the FBI with pictures of
his toilet, with documents in it circulating as
he pled the fifth yesterday, more than 400 times
when deposed by the New York attorney general.
Things aren't looking very good for trumpworld
and things are looking increasingly good for a Joe
Biden. Now, is it good that gas prices are low?
One of the things that we have to understand
is that it's not necessarily good for the long
term for gas to be so cheap in the
United States. I have said before,
gasoline prices in the United States are
not accurate in the sense of representing
the true cost of a gallon of gas, particularly
including the environmental cost of a gallon
of gas. When gas is more expensive, people tend
to use less of it. And when you look at Europe,
you see smaller vehicles and people being much
more judicious in terms of their road trips.
I've done road trips and done extensive
driving and we think now Spain, France,
Italy. At minimum, if not other places as well.
And with tiny vehicles, I mean, tiny vehicles,
compact cars, little stick shift, compact cars
that I rent. It's stunning when I don't drive
that much. And the gas bill is €70. And if in
the United States, gas prices were similar to
those in Europe, which are arguably more accurate
in representing the true cost of a gallon of gas,
people would drive a lot less and we would be
doing less damage to the environment. And so
while by traditional economic standards,
inflation down, gas prices down, stocks up,
all of this stuff looks good for Biden. I
also am painfully aware of the fact that
higher gas prices encourage people to get off of
gas powered vehicles and move over to electrics,
to drive less, to look for a more fuel efficient
vehicles. So these are all double edged swords,
but by the standard indicators we look at, things
are looking really good. Doesn't mean there isn't
poverty, inequality, lack of access to health
care. Of course, we haven't solved the economy
overnight, but many of the indicators Republican
themselves look at are looking very, very good.